dan quinn out in atlanta we kind of felt
it coming although it wasn't quite clear
because of the fact that last year they
were one and seven at the bye arthur
blank didn't fire dan quinn they
finished six and two and then he had to
give him another chance well
the shelf life on the next chance five
total games quinn out after yesterday's
loss to the panthers there was buzz
yesterday that it was an important game
for quinn and it was important not just
for quinn chris but for general manager
thomas dimitrov that's the one that
surprises me
that dimitrov is gone too and i think
the fact that the texans got rid of
coach slash gm bill o'brien last week
and are now officially looking for both
i think that made arthur blank realize
why wait we're going to be looking for
both let's start the search now because
there's another franchise already
looking for a gm and then we'll be
looking for a coach we want to have the
ability to pursue a gm consider our gm
options while the texans are and we
don't want to do it behind thomas de
mitroff's back yeah right i mean at this
point it seemed inevitable so like just
rip the band-aid and move on i mean i
don't think any of us thought like it
was it's not gonna change anything
drastic there with atlanta and
yeah i i mean i i think you're right
mike you said it last week
you thought the billy o'brien firing
might embolden some other teams to make
these type of moves and you you were
exactly right and then again the way the
game looked yesterday once again where
yeah atlanta
all these high-priced talent everything
like that
losing to the rebuilding
carolina panthers that just couldn't
have sat well with arthur blank so i
understand it dan quinn i i've got to
think he had lost the the ear of the
team a little bit and thomas dimitroff
as we've talked about a lot the team was
just too top-heavy there's nothing more
to it you there's only a few guys a few
guys getting a huge chunk of the salary
cap and we saw for like the third year
in a row when they get injured they
can't survive or win games uh because of
the thinness of their team
too many big leads blown which just will
drive an owner even crazier and now they
have to go forward and i haven't seen
anything about the interim coach they've
got two former head coaches on staff
dirk cutter formerly of the bucks raheem
morris formerly of the bucks i don't
know who you give the whistle to and i
somebody suggested to me last night
could they actually hire bill o'brien to
come be the coach of the team well you
you rarely if ever see someone from
outside the building come in during the
season and what they'd have to do is the
full search rooney rule compliant just
to hire the interim coach if they go
outside the building and then do it all
again after the season ends including
with the interim coach it's not like you
can make a permanent hire during the
season i think anyone outside of the
falcons organization is slim but it is
surprising to me that they've yet
to tell us
and maybe they've yet to decide who's
going to take over chris yeah i mean it
is a little weird you usually hear those
type of things like that night or you
know right after the firing oh this guy
will take over as the interim head coach
i just wonder what this brings with
atlanta all together you know mike i
really do you you heard me say
the other day if i'm atlanta with the
way their team looks i'm putting julio
jones on the trade block you know i am
and now it's a lot of money and they
might have to pay part of that salary
but they might have to start looking at
doing like miami dolphin type things
where we trade away we might pay a
little money sure but we're going to get
assets and rebuild this team and do it
that way and i'd be interested to see if
they take that route here
and the other question becomes and this
is a topic for a different day what does
the new regime think of matt ryan who is
creeping uh toward 40. right he's older
than you think and
who knows what the next coaching gm will
want to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports